[Music]
can you imagine a country that irrigates
plants
with salt water a country that has
managed to transform an arid
barren desert into lush fields of crops
a country that despite being located in
one of the driest and most arid places
on earth
has been able to obtain an almost
unlimited supply of water well the truth
is that it is not a mirage
this place really exists a large part of
its territory is located in the negev
and judean deserts and it's called
israel we are talking about the only
country on planet earth that today has a
less desert area than it did 50 years
ago in addition
each year the country exports more than
2 billion us dollars worth of
agricultural products mainly fresh
produce such as fruits and vegetables
and this is exactly what we're going to
be talking about in this video about how
israel has been able to turn the desert
itself
into an orchard about how this country
has overcome water scarcity by the way
this video was made thanks to our
patreon community that's where this
topic was chosen so it is especially
dedicated to all of you who support us
on patreon let's get started
a confidential u.s national intelligence
council report released in 2012 and
later partially declassified pointed to
a future water crisis
a huge global water crisis according to
this report
water consumption is above any
sustainable parameter there are more and
more of us
and we use more and more water we
consume more meat have more gardens
more swimming pools and consume more
energy
these are all things that believe me
require a lot of water for example
producing
one kilo just one kilo of meat consumes
17 times more water than producing one
kilo of corn
thus the report agreed with other expert
information that more than 20
of the world's population more than 1.5
billion people will suffer greatly from
this water crisis in the coming decades
that's 1.5 billion people who will have
serious
very serious problems in accessing a
regular water supply we're talking about
a crisis that would threaten the entire
global food supply and don't think for a
moment that it would be limited to
punishing the poorest countries for
example the san joaquin valley in
california the heartland of california's
quality agriculture could disappear at
least as we know it today and that's
that's what has led us to a key question
in this video are we all doomed to water
scarcity well i think that the time has
come to take a look at one of the most
arid and barren places on the planet
[Music]
no less than 60 percent of israeli
territory is covered by desert which
explains why the relationship of these
people with water is so close that it is
constantly present whether in culture
politics or even religion in fact one of
the best known jewish prayers the shema
warns that the punishment of not
fulfilling god's commandments would be
specifically that the rain will stop
falling
despite this as i'm sure you all know
israel is a prosperous country a major
agri-food exporter and has an abundant
and guaranteed supply of water in fact
it even supplies water to its neighbors
so the question
the big question we can ask ourselves is
how on earth have they managed to
overcome water scarcity what can other
countries learn from israel are we
facing a future with
water or a future of thirst in this
video we're going to answer all these
questions
but first we have to start at the
beginning we need to look at a little
bit
of history
[Music]
the arteries of israel
in the late 1920s economists advising
the british government which at the time
controlled this territory stated that
the immigration of more jews to
palestine was not sustainable and it was
not sustainable because
according to their calculations the
water resources were so limited that it
was impossible to sustain more than 2
million people yes i know today there
are more than
14 million you know expert forecasts the
fact is
that from that very moment the jewish
organizations in the area
understood that their future depended on
increasing water resources he had to
find water at all costs
for the fields for the new settlers that
might arrive and in order to be able to
build a new israel
[Music]
but there was a problem most of the
country was desert arid and dry
the available water resources were
concentrated in the north but jews were
settling mostly around the region's new
big city
tel aviv located in the centre of the
country so to resolve this conundrum
following the publication of the british
report in 1939 one of the country's most
renowned hydraulic engineers
simcha blas a polish immigrant was
commissioned to design
a water plan it was nothing short of the
plan that was to guarantee israel's
future
[Music]
and you know what no sooner said than
done that is exactly what he did
displaying all his ingenuity and daring
mr blass
designed a three-phase plan basically
the plan that was implemented over
decades has made
israel's demographic and economic
takeoff possible you see the first phase
consisted of extracting water by
drilling deep bore holes sim char blast
was convinced that under the subsoil of
israel even in the areas as arid as the
negev desert there was water so he set
out to find it
in order to supply new farms of course
even if successful
such an operation would not be enough
the country would have to use every last
drop that was available that is they had
to move the water from where it was
relatively abundant to where it was
needed
for this precise reason the next two
phases were centered on this idea
the second phase aimed to pump the water
from the jordan river the most important
river in the region
to the south east even reaching the
negev desert itself
an uninhabited area where new settlers
would be able to settle and grow their
crops
but by far the most significant part of
the plan was the third phase the
construction of the national aqueduct
we're talking about a huge diversion of
more than 100 kilometers that was to
transfer water from the north of the
country
particularly from the sea of galilee to
the largest freshwater lake in the
country to where it was needed while
also connecting the resources developed
in the previous phase in other words
what simcha blast proposed was a huge
investment plan to create the arteries
of israel that is a huge water system
that would guarantee access to fresh
water throughout the country and take
note because if there was one thing that
was clear it was that implementing this
plan was
urgent look at this
[Music]
on the day of the declaration of
independence of the hebrew state
14th of may 1948 israel had 806 000
inhabitants within the following three
years alone almost 700
000 more people arrived in the country
obviously the vast majority of them came
from europe naturally to suddenly care
for so many people
feed them and help them find a job to
support themselves required lots and
lots of water thus
water restrictions became more and more
demanding and putting simcha blass's
plan in place was a matter of the utmost
urgency
the problem is that it took a lot of
money and we're not exactly talking
about the country that was rich
at that time not to mention that the few
resources available to the fledgling
israeli government went largely to
security and defense so the question was
how to get it done well it was here that
the then prime minister of israel ben
gurion made one of the most
controversial decisions in the history
of israel a decision that could even end
up
leading to a civil conflict
in the early 1950s ben gurion agreed to
sign a reparations agreement with conrad
adenauer's federal republic of germany
an agreement whereby the state of israel
received an indemnity of three billion
marks as compensation for nazi crimes
and the theft and destruction of jewish
property during the time of the third
reich
and it was tremendously unpopular except
compensation for such a pain
many israelis felt that their pain was
being bought that one of the most tragic
events in human history was being
commodified by the way if you are
interested in military history let me
take an opportunity to recommend
this video about the second world war
just published on our sister channel
visual academy you can watch in full by
clicking the link in the description and
now back to our video
there were protests demonstrations
violent clashes with security forces and
in the end
the nesit the israeli parliament
approved the agreement by only two votes
[Music]
nevertheless the money was there the
jordan river diversion was completed in
1955 and over the next few years the
country was turned upside down the
national aqueduct involved building
pipes canals and small reservoirs all
over the country the main network itself
had to be basically subterranean and be
able to withstand any attack that might
occur
thousands and thousands of people worked
on this immense project and the per
capita expenditure was greater than that
of the panama canal itself but finally
in 1964 the national aqueduct became a
reality
water supply was finally guaranteed
throughout the country without these
immense works we can say that the
enormous economic and demographic growth
that israel has experienced would not
have been possible however
today israel has more than 9 million
inhabitants and a modern economy so
more needs to be done much more
[Music]
israel needs more water
with the beginning of the 21st century
problems with water supply were once
again
on the agenda and it was here that a
whole new revolution was set in motion
you see
in 2006 the decision was made to
transfer the management of the water
system from the political level to the
technocratic level that is the
politicians were no longer in charge and
the israel water authority
was created an agency whose mission it
is to manage the system in a
professional manner
and boy did they do it in 2008 this
water authority made a very
controversial decision
everyone would have to pay the actual
cost of providing water
until then as in most countries in the
world the price of water was subsidised
by the government
people understand that water is a
treasure but they don't understand why
they have to pay for it they see rain
and they think water is free
and they are right the water is free but
safe reliable
always available water is not free and
cannot be free
building infrastructure is not free
senior member of the israeli water
authority the measure had
two very clear objectives one had to
promote saving water you know if you
have to pay more
you use less and on the other hand to
increase the system's revenues to be
able to build more infrastructure and
improve its maintenance but that was not
all
[Music]
this agency also took control of water
distribution and wastewater management
away from the municipalities in exchange
it created a system of 55 municipal
companies that had to operate under
market criteria to manage the entire
network
the money collected would no longer go
to municipal budgets but improving the
system for example to prevent water
leaks from
pipes which in many cities accounts for
a loss of more than 30
of all water in the case of israel that
figure is well below 10
this way if a mayor wants to water the
municipal parks he no longer has free
water to do so and he has to pay the
real price
at the end of the day the measure was a
complete and resounding success
without having to limit supply public
and private residential water
consumption fell by almost 20 percent
nationwide for example
in parks and gardens many plants were
replaced by species that were better
adapted to the area and consumed less
water and then in agriculture the same
thing happened
but that's not all to boost water
innovation the government set up plans
to support investment in innovation by
these new companies the idea was to turn
israeli cities into veritable water
laboratories companies compete for funds
while innovations allow them to improve
their bottom line
[Music]
and so that's exactly how the drought
was beaten again during the early years
of this 21st century but you know what
we're not done yet it is one thing to
avoid drought it is
quite another to have all the water you
want and moreover
to turn it into a big business and
that's exactly what israel has achieved
listen up
ingenuity is the key
[Applause]
israel is a country known for three
things the mossad the efficiency of its
armed
forces and also for innovation in fact
it is known
as the startup nation and in the case of
water management which is a national
priority it was to be no different
especially in the field of agriculture
which after all accounts for 55
of all water consumption in israel and
yes it was precisely in this country
that one of the great agricultural
revolutions of recent decades took place
drip irrigation a technique that saves
up to 60 of water while improving crop
yields we're talking about a technique
that consists of watering a plant drop
by drop directly to the root
and that in recent years has been
improved with what is known as
fertigation
that is drip irrigation in which
fertilizers are also included drop by
drop and even with nutrition the latest
in agricultural technology
in this case drip irrigation supplies
the plants with everything they need to
grow so that even huge plantations can
be developed on the very sand of the
desert
with nutrigation crops can grow anywhere
desert stand can be used to hold the
plant in place
and nutrient water is administered by
drip irrigation that takes care of the
rest
rafi and they are even now introducing
tiny devices that are placed on the
roots
and detect when exactly the plants need
to be watered well the fact is that all
these technologies have been developed
mainly by
israeli companies but that's not all
there is to it either another field in
which the israelis are particularly good
is seeds both traditional and
genetically modified seeds
this has allowed them for example to
reduce the water consumption of each
plant
and they have even developed seeds that
could be irrigated with slightly salty
water such as brackish water which is a
type of water that is found in large
quantities in the subsoil throughout the
middle east but which was always thought
to be useless
yes that's right in israel you can find
melons
tomatoes peppers or i don't know
eggplants among many other kinds of
fruits and vegetables that are irrigated
with a mixture of fresh water and salt
water but wait there's more
along with the infrastructure linked to
the national aqueduct in recent years
this country has developed a second
infrastructure to distribute treated
wastewater
throughout the country so that no less
than 85 percent of all wastewater is
reused basically for agriculture and
also to irrigate for example
parks or golf courses
believe me there is nothing like that in
the rest of the world
to top it off israel has also become one
of the world leaders in desalination
technology in fact one of the largest
plants in the world
in terms of volume and efficiency is
located in the tel aviv area the sorek
plant which is capable of processing
more than 600 million liters of water
per day and this is how israel has
overcome the droughts that have plagued
this region of the world for millennia
israel a country located in dry arids
terrain now has
all the water it could ever need it even
supplies water to palestine and jordan
all this has been achieved through
engineering
innovation and also very importantly the
use of the pricing system but having
reached this point it's
your turn what do you think of israel's
commitment to water supply do you think
this is the way forward to avoid water
crisis leave us your answers in the
comments and if you found this video
interesting don't forget to give it a
like and before i finish
thank you very much to all of you who
support us on patreon i really hope that
you liked this video that you chose
best regards see you next time and if
you want to learn more about politics
and hear
even more of my lovely voice you can
join us at
reconsider media we have a podcast at
reconsider media.com
podcast see you there